hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so as usual i'm here to make some
technical analysis
i want to go with you through all the
amazing week that we had on amc
with 75 reached again this was my target
and
we had this impressive roller coaster a
lot of information
to get from it so i'm gonna give you as
usual guys my different scenarios
and what you are here for my new target
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so let's start on the
hourly time frame
because you know all the price action
that happened in the past
week two weeks is very very important
and the best way to see it is to be on
the hourly time frame because things go
really fast here so this is my last
drawings that i'm keeping here for now
so let me analyze
quickly with you guys what happened here
so i had basically four scenarios in
my last video i was giving you four
scenarios all of them
all of them were going to 65. i also had
a target
at 75 like in the video i did one week
ago
and basically we went to 73 as a maximum
level so it was the area i was targeting
i have eliminated
two scenarios you know basically i built
four scenarios and i kept those
two guys and the one that played out was
the first one
so now i can eliminate this one and this
is what we had
so very quickly the way i found this i'm
gonna show you guys this again because
you know when something is working you
need to keep applying it
because usually it's going to keep
working so i just
apply the fib extension ratios to the
third wave
of my last five waves development
and this was giving me guys here
[Music]
and this was giving me 65 as a target so
we
went slightly above it but you can see
that basically the consolidation guys
because even on a you know when the
price is going so quickly from
one side to the other you can see yes
that the consolidation happened
around the 65 level that here has been
retested and then you know finally we
got
rejected so this is what happened i
think this was on wednesday and then
thursday was like a very animated day
guys we are here making some
very very strong moves guys you know
losing 50
then taking back 84
i mean guys this is just incredible and
i think that this will keep happening
so i have here a lot of information i'm
gonna do what i usually do with you guys
i'm gonna first
build my different scenarios and then
i'm gonna give you my preferred one i'm
gonna give you what you guys looking for
which is basically
my new target you're gonna have it
you're gonna see and you're gonna be i
think happy about it
i'm also gonna give you here in this
video how to actually
enter uh this trade if you want to be
in the next move so let's do things step
by step
so we here finished this five waves
impulse
so right now we need to go to the larger
degree wave counting and see what is
happening so here we have a one
here we have a two here we have a three
all right so this was the plan guys
the plan was that we finished this third
wave
which is now done i didn't know if it
was finished or not before
now i know that this it's finished here
we're gonna
retrace probably to the 35 area
like i told you guys in my last video
and
then we probably gonna go to much
higher levels again the reason behind
guys
is just you know that moves up develop
in five ways
you know this can be explained by some
psychological mechanisms
you can just go and uh click on the link
in the description of this video
and i'm explaining you're gonna
basically receive a free training where
i explain everything about idiot wave
theory
and basically the third wave is where
you have the most grid
but then you have the fifth wave and the
fifth wave is usually
weaker little bit and you have different
type of investors
all of those who were not in the third
wave and that heard
you know of everything that happened
here everybody's talking about amc right
now
and a lot of people want to be into this
wave and
in this fifth wave usually professional
investors are
selling and retail investor is buying so
i don't know on which side you want to
be but this fifth wave is
usually very hard to trade but anyway
so here the target is
we measure the third wave as usual guys
we measured the third wave
and we applied to the bottom of the
force wave so it's a target
of 135 36
you know something like this but we need
to be careful when the third wave is
that strong that extended
sometimes the fifth wave only completes
a one-to-one relationship so
then it would go only to 97 so
my preferred scenario is 135
but i also keep in mind that 97
is a likely scenario is is something
that you know could
happen as well then we would need to see
what is happening in this fifth wave and
do the same kind of exercise
to know if we're going to 100 or if
we're going to 135
one more thing i want to give you here
guys so when you analyze this price
action what you can see is that
so basically this fifth wave is complete
sure
sorry this third wave is complete but we
could also have
a different counting and i think it's
worth uh showing you guys this
so this would be my second scenario is
that
here we have a one so let me put it in a
different color
here we have a one here we have a two
here we have a three
actually so the three is not going here
and we already have four and five
like this because in the third wave here
i would also need guys to have
five waves as usual so then it means
that this one is
coming here
up rebuilding quickly this with you guys
sorry it's like this
all right then here i have a four
five okay so in this situation guys
in this situation look at the yellow one
the yellow one is this one
what do you see guys here what do you
see to me it's kind of
obvious so then let me get rid of the
blue one
we would be in this situation this is
another counting
that you know is my second scenario i
want to show you guys this to you
and you're going to see that my
conclusion is not going to be very
different
but it would just
be a different counting inside so we
would have different uh retracements
in terms of levels and in time i mean
when this levels would be reached in the
retracements
and the thing is that here when you look
at
this wave counting something to me
doesn't look good
so the first thing is that this five
wave development here
in purple you know it's not i mean it's
not
looking the way it usually looks the
fifth wave here is
much shorter compared to the third wave
so i could also make a counting like
this
this could be good as well but even if i
do this
i still have some issues in my yellow
counting
here is that look at the second wave the
second wave
is a zigzag that lasts around so from
the 18th of may
to the 24th of may so roughly one week
and here we have the retracement of
only two days right so you can see that
something is not fitting well
here but even if this would be true guys
even if this would be true let me show
you what we would still have
this would still be like this you know
so i can take scenario one scenario two
the outcome is the same guys and what is
interesting
so the outcome is the same is that we're
going to you know we're gonna do
this time one two one or one two one
point six one eight
extension so this time we could go to
145
or to 100 or three all right so those
this is my second scenario
but once again i don't like the counting
here so let me go back to my first
scenario that to me
was fitting much better here we are so
this is my
first scenario guys so my first scenario
is that we retrace here
now why are we gonna retrace to 35 so
let me give you a few reasons for this
usually false waves they like to retrace
to the top of the third wave
on the bottom of the force wave of the
previous wave
development so here the previous wave
development is the purple one
and my fourth wave here let me put this
in yellow guys i prefer the yellow color
for this one
so and the false wave would retrace
either to the top of the third wave and
that's why i gave you already in my
previous video
35 guys so we went to 37 i think we're
gonna go to 35 ultimately i'm gonna
explain very soon why
so either we go to 35 or we go to 26 all
right which is the bottom of the false
wave
this is the reason why it's very
important you guys have the right
counting in your previous wave
because the retracement of the coming
wave
are actually based on the highs and the
lows
of the previous wave so that's why your
counting
needs to fit the best even if the wave
is done
is complete it's still going to have an
impact on the new wave development
so here like i said 35 or 26
but let me give you some hints about
where we actually gonna go because here
once again
this is my perfect scenario guys so here
i have an abc
so guys you know that when you have an
abc
in the second wave you usually have a
flat in the force wave
and what are we having here guys what
are we having here
look at this it's starting here going
back
almost to the same level so this is
the beginning of a flat so i want to
eliminate
from here this exact scenario to go to
the 26th level
we would need to do something like this
with the zigzag so the first thing is
that here we have a zigzag so here
expect a flat but this is not
enough to actually be convinced that
we're not going to break 35
but when i see that the retracement here
after my
wave a was complete we started the wave
b and wave b
went to guys 68.71
so in terms of retracement because this
is what is important how
much have we retraced from wave a we
have retraced
more than 78.6
which makes our pattern a flat this is a
flat guys
so if it's a flat wave c cannot go
too deep after wave a it cannot be very
longer it can be slightly longer that's
why wave a went to 37
i expect wave c to go to 35 maybe you
know slightly
break it you know when the price action
is so
impulsive and so strong uh we sometimes
have what we call
access so it's probably people having
stop losses around the 35 levels so if
we go
just to 20 34.95 those stop loss are
gonna just
you know create a domino effect that can
go very quickly to maybe 30
or 32 and then bounce back so we need
to accept that when the price action is
so strong we might have some
excesses and this is the reason why wave
c can go slightly below 25 but let's say
35 is the
theoretical perfect scenario so this is
my view guys
so this is my first scenario i showed
you my second scenario it's just the
same one let me show you quickly again
i'm not gonna
go with you through the counting here
again
but basically my second scenario is we
do this
and same thing all right
now remember guys what i told you my
previous video
when you are actually you know long in
this kind of environment you don't want
to sell you want to see how how we can
go
when we reach some major targets it's
good to take some profits i know you
guys don't like to sell i'm just telling
you
as a pro trader what i would do i would
have sold actually
35 put back 26 if i was quick enough
maybe not but i would have definitely
not sold everything at 35
then i would have sold 65 75 i wouldn't
have
been executed i would then be a buyer at
35
only if i have sold at 65 if not then i
wouldn't be
a buyer here just keep my position so if
you guys haven't touched anything
i think your position is just good like
this and
just keeping your shares is good but
remember that
we need to be aware so let me get rid of
this
i'm just going to keep here my scenario
you need to be aware
that we're looking for some reversal
patterns
so we're not looking for it because we
want to see them we're looking for it
because we need to be aware that this
can happen
let me show you guys again what happened
the previous time in january when we had
this kind of movements
we had here the same roller coaster with
red days guys one two three four
five five red days in a row here i'm
having two red days i don't like red
days
red days means that it doesn't mean you
can have a bullish red day it just means
that the close level was below the open
level
it means that sellers won the daily
battle that
happened and if they win too many of
those they're gonna
have more confidence and they're gonna
keep doing it so
here i have two red days i'm looking for
some reversal patterns i told you guys
like the island reversal
some bearish and gold things go check it
out guys i'm
not gonna explain here what are those
patterns but i don't see
them here here i have actually a bearish
angle thing
it's basically when the candle here is
eating totally the previous candle and
you had a strong move up
then a red candle eating the previous
candle like here here the option is
higher than here the close is lower than
the option of this one
because it was a green day actually and
then we had this you know move down
but i'm looking more at daily reversal
patterns because
you know we're here analyzing a longer
term price action
so i'm keeping an eye on it for now this
is clean to me
now let me show you guys some very
interesting data
uh short interest option market let's i
want to update you guys on this
you're gonna see we have some very very
cool things and yes so let's start first
on the option market
so this was what i had the previous time
i did it
remember guys we had the 70 strike calls
opening and all the calls all the
strikes above 40 happened a few days ago
and uh when i did my last update on
tuesday uh or wednesday
i had nothing here and i i was telling
you guys that we want to see those uh
strike
that this high strikes uh having strong
positions and exposure again
so that the gamma squeeze can happen
again so now i'm gonna update this with
you
all right here we go guys here we go so
we have more shares
from 104 million shares equivalent we
have 107
so more shares where have they been
bought
guys look this is worrying so for now
it's not very big yet
seven million shares equivalent and so
we have a total of at 37 we were at 18
of short interest synthetic short
interest if
we go to 47 which is the closing level
of
friday we are 20 guys 4 billion usd
synthetic short exposure on the option
market of amc
once again as i showed you very quickly
what i do here i take
all the maturities all the listed
maturities i take all the open interest
all the volatilities i compute the delta
myself guys
using this formula here you can see you
know it's just black shells formula guys
and i
do this for all the options and then i
just sum it up guys
and i give you here the real synthetic
short interest
that is creating the gamma squeeze that
is creating a potential short squeeze as
well
so this data is very interesting to me
to watch and i'm keeping
keeping an eye on the volatility here so
hold on 340 percent guys for the 70
strike call of the july maturity
guys this is good this is good market
makers are very scared
uh those volatility are just keep keep
keep going higher and higher every
a week so this is good this is bullish
so i can see you guys here this bullish
momentum happening again
with the 70 strike calls getting
both massively so you know this is going
to create the same kind of
bullish momentum that we had since amc
is actually going higher every day
let me give you an update here on those
numbers guys so here i keep an eye on
the equity float the outstanding number
of shares the short interest very
important
information i then compute the total
short which is the sum of the synthetic
short and the regular short interest so
as
the 14th of may guys uh we are having
so i'm using 14 of my data because you
know this data
is published every two weeks and if i
check the 28th
of may here i don't have the data yet
it has not been released as you can see
here i don't have the data
so i'm waiting for this data to arrive
because i really want to know guys if
hedges
are actually shorting more shares or not
if yes this is once again very good guys
very good we need
hedge funds to you know play their role
in this
move up which is basically shooting
shares
buying them higher that's what they do
and they're helping the price action to
develop higher
what i see what i don't like guys uh is
that amc is emitting more shares guys
so they said they won't emit more shares
but they do
actually they emitted 50 million of
shares but once again this money is
going to be used to grow the company so
actually it's fine all right it's fine
but
apes need to stay strong if you know the
price action needs to go higher because
if
amc and hedge funds are selling you need
to have a massive buying power as well
all right so i'm going to keep here the
4th of june
because this is the latest data i have
so here i don't have it up so what i'm
having guys is this so 40
of total short interest so guys this is
the highest
level almost we had since so this year
is the highest level
and it's close to the highest level we
had last year as well
so you can see that the same situation
is starting to happen
and i still see some upside potential on
the stock as i
showed you guys so repeat my support
levels are 35
and 26 most likely 35 would hold maybe
with a bit of excess
next week i expect the new target to be
reached
next week as well so 97 or 135
let's see 135 might be more likely but
we need to see what is going to happen
during the move
up and yeah that's it for me so i hope
you guys enjoyed this video i hope this
would help you to understand
how the press action actually develops
even in
this kind of environment you can still
apply the same methods as long as you
know how to use it
so if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys